كان مغرما بالعاب الفيديو
عاشق الطيران منذ صغره وكان يحلم ان يصبح
طيارا في المستقبل
وعندما اصبح شابا نجح في الحصول على وظيفه
كوكيل خدمه في مطار في واشنطن ريتشارد
راسل صاحب اغرب عمليه اختطاف لطائره في
امريكا
في العاشر من اغسطس عام 2018 كان ريتشارد
راسل على عمله عندما راودته فكره مجنونه
دخل من هذه البوابه دون ان يعترضه احد فقد
كانت لديه صلاحيه العبور لارضيه المطار
بسبب طبيعه عمله كعامل سحب للطائرات ثم
اختطف هذه الطائره التي تتجاوز قيمتها 30
مليون دولار
[موسيقى]
كان رجلا محبوبا وهادئا ولم يتوقع احد انه
سيرتكب فعلا جنونيا كهذا كان لا يجيد
الطيران ولم تكن لديه اي رخصه في المجال
الجوي لكنه سرعان ما اقلع بالطائره وحلق
بالهواء مستعرضا قدراته في الطيران لم يكن
لدى راسل رخصه طيار لقد قام بالمناورات
الجويه بشكل لا يصدق خلال محادثته مع برج
المراقبه قال انه يعرف قليلا عما يفعله
وان لديه خبره من العاب الفيديو
بمجرد اقلاعه تواصل برج المراقبه مع رسل
وظل يرشده نحو مسار بعيد عن الاماكن
الماهوله لتجنب وقوع الكارثه والغريب ان
راسلكان يتجاوب معهم بمرح شديد البرج
اقترح عليه الهبوط في قاعده لوسماكورد
المشتركه لكنه رفض ذلك بسخريه ايضا
هؤلاء رجال سيضربونني اذا حاولت الهبوط
هناك اعتقد انني قد افسدت شيئا هناك ايضا
لا اريد ان افعل ذلك لكن انهبطت بنجاح هل
تعطونني وظيفه طيار لديكم
طائرتان مقاتلتان من طراز اف 15 ايجل
اقلعت الاعتراض طائره رسم الا انه تمكن من
المناوره وظل محلقا في السماء لاكثر من
سبعين دقيقه وفي الدقائق الاخيره من
الاتصال ببرج المراقبه اعتذر لاصدقائه
وعائلته قائلا انه كان شخصا محقما لاحقا
وفي جزيره كترون الصغيره وشبه الخاليه من
السكان في مقاطعه بيرست واشنطن هوى راسل
بطائرته وسط هذه الاشجار انفجرت الطائره
واحترقت واحترق معها رسل في حادثه هي
الاغرب في سجل حوادث اختطاف الطائرات في
امريكا والعالم